have you heard this thing that's blowing
up all over the news it's everywhere
I've been tweeted about this more in the
last 24 hours than anything I could
think of in a long time
teen Sue's parents for cash
college tuition New Jersey teenager
claiming that her mother and father
tossed her out of the home and cut her
off financially is suing them for
immediate support current private school
fees and future college tuition the
parents meanwhile say that daughter
Rachel Channing 18 years old I think
that's a legal adult moved out
voluntarily after refusing to abide by
their rules
we love our child we miss her this is
terrible it's killing me and my wife
Rachel's father Sean Canning Town
Administrator retired police officer
tells the Daily Record we have a child
we went home we're not too chrome
draconian and now we're getting hauled
into court she's demanding that we pay
her bills but she doesn't want to live
at home and she's saying I don't want to
live under your rules the rules he notes
include reconsidering her relationship
with a boyfriend who may be a bad
influence being disrespectful and
abiding by curfew for months Rachel an
honor student cheerleader lacrosse
players been living with the family of
her best friend and classmate Jamie in
glee CEO who's father inglesina whose
father attorney John Inglis Eno
pronouncing that wrong probably is
bankrolling Rachel's lawsuit
Rachel alleges that her parents decided
to cut her off from all support both
financially and emotionally as of her
18th birthday see this is what happens
America when you become a bunch of
wusses I got to tell you I'm just I'm
appalled I want to just do something
with a little 18 year old brat but more
so her her caretaker and the one funding
the lawsuit her attorney and even her
parents what a disastrous group of
people you people are all of you your
shameful your shameful to start with I
got to tell you I'm just old school I am
draconian my children would be afraid to
do
it would be afraid they would come up
missing or missing parts at least I'm
serious when we go by the Bill Cosby
rule we brought you into this world we
can take you out I can make another one
looks just like you and so just start
this crap
see this started when the kid was four
years old this started in a culture
where we're so now kids centric in an
effort to love our children we are now
allow them to run our lives and that's
not loving your children by the way
loving your children of course they are
they're do food and water and clothes
and shelter and love and nurturing they
are not in freakin charge though now
some of your households they're in
charge because some of your parents
aren't parents your Lissa's and your the
problem with America right now because
you're raising people like this brat and
so I don't know my idea is I think she
should go to jail for about 30 days for
tying up resources of the court you're
an 18 year old adult you're on your own
because you decide not to follow your
the rules of the family so you know
you're on your own kiddo you made this
decision you can come in at curfew you
cannot be disrespectful and you can live
here or you can be on your own and
figure it out but you don't get to leave
and take my money that's not how this
works
so I think the judge or the sitter in
jail for about 30 days let's see how
that lacrosse thing works there see how
that honor student stuff works in jail
and I think the guy funding our stuff
probably ought to sit there in the next
cell over on because he's some kind of
liberal twit and the attorney should be
disbarred but you know it's just a sad
commentary on our culture is in general
it's unbelievable that that that this
even I mean it's such a frivolous
lawsuit that seriously the attorney that
there are there are procedures to punish
attorneys for filing frivolous lawsuits
this is absolutely ridiculous it's like
me suing you because you won't give me
money I'm an adult you're an adult
you know I think you ought to take care
of me I think I'm gonna sue you so you
should give me some money she's an adult
she's a legal adult she's 18 years old
now obviously she's not an adult she's
obviously a freakin child but um this is
just this is unbelievable it's
unbelievable you know I'm but it did it
started a long time before she had to be
put out at 18 it started you know when
she was four and she threw a temper fit
in the middle of the cereal aisle in the
grocery store and her mommy stood back
and went oh I don't know what to do
her daddy stood back and didn't have a
backbone and said oh I don't know how to
handle a child he's freaking out of
control well I got to tell you we raised
three very competent and very confident
young adults now they're all adults and
they're all mean Daniel's are within
months of being on his own he'll
graduate from college in just a few
months and par the way we raised them is
is they knew exactly how things work and
the way things work is if you're in my
house you're gonna do what I say and
I'll let you live that's how it works
is this not heart if I say brush your
teeth I don't need to say it twice once
was enough
second time there's action gonna follow
you just do it and that's not mean it's
not mean cuz I love you and I'm only
asking you to do things that are for
your own good I'm there to teach you and
grow you into an adult and you're not
I'm not here for your entertainment or
your pleasure and I don't serve you I'm
not your servant in that regard I do
serve my household as a servant leader
but I'm not confused about this the
problem is you just we've raced off
everybody gets a trophy bunch of wusses
in this culture it's just out of control
and your parents call that loving your
children some of you it's not loving
your children you're just a wuss as all
it is and so
your 13 year old daughter walks out of
the house looking like a streetwalker
she looks like she needs to go down that
end of town and walk down the street and
mommy thinks that's called high fashion
it's not high fashion she looks like a
prostitute and you dads are standing
back letting her do that and then wonder
why we've got some of the problems we've
got in this culture yeah we had that
discussion a time or two that's one of
the biggest fights I had with my wife no
you can take all that crap back buy
something for that child that causes men
to look at her eyes because I am a man
and I know how that stuff works this
isn't hard guys this isn't hard it's
loving your children well and you put
together a situation where the mom and
dad are in charge they're in charge and
if you don't then you get idiots like
you've raised this one to be this poor
little idiot judge set her in jail for
about 30 days for tying up courts time
that should have been used for important
things maybe she can move on with her
life then as apparently her dad and mom
aren't gonna stand up to her maybe they
will in this lawsuit finally oh my gosh
what a disaster this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you
you